hey guys it's Friday and it is time for
us to dig into three of the biggest news
stories of the week in video games and
it is two things also it is the end of
DanceSport news for 2017 and it is the
end of me as a host for GameSpot news
this will be my last episode so I hope
you enjoy or enjoyed my time here and
please leave any comments re neckbeard
straight down below but for now let's
dig into some stories pop G's out on
console holy crap
is it run badly you took a game that was
already shaky on PC the best times and
inevitably it's having some problems on
xbox it is part of the early access
program you know sorry it's not expected
to be a complete product as yet that's
it it does cost money and it does run
off right so digital foundry has
conducted a bunch of tests on pub G on
Xbox one and they found that the
framerate will just inexplicably drop to
around 20 frames per second quite
regularly stuff like textures don't load
in if you see another player it's it's
quite common for the frame rate to drop
to 20 frames per second but what they do
know and what I've found playing it
actually is that it's it's actually
still quite playable and very very
enjoyable which I guess is a testament
to the game as a as a as a product as a
game itself but yeah it definitely
doesn't run so hard and unfortunately
the Xbox one X does run it better and
the Xbox one and Xbox 1s there are more
noticeable issues but I yeah I'm
enjoying it it's still very very fun I
will say ABCD always be closing doors
guys cuz it seems a lot of you haven't
played pub G before I'm seeing lots of
open doors and look behind you hold down
right right bumper and then flip that
around when you're running number four
the other day and was promptly runner oh
yeah let's not talk about that something
about still having I still haven't got a
chicken dinner okay just look two things
in this world The Simpsons see and
Disneyland is there any way we can get
both of those properties together in
some capacity I mean now that the
massive conglomerate
that is Disney has acquired Fox for 15
2.4 billion dollars so it seems like
that's probably gonna happen
oh boy you heard it here first The
Simpsons ride coming to Disneyland
so yeah Disney Disney has acquired Fox's
entertainment assets for that process
for a staggering amount of money which
of course is exciting for people who are
into the Marvel films because Fox and
there's obviously been that split
between rights to characters such as the
Fantastic Four yeah who were at Fox the
x-men yeah now if Disney takes them back
x-men are now in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yeah crazy
so Wolverine yeah Wolverine and Deadpool
can come along and help out the Avengers
at some point because that's what you
need you need you definitely want Tony
Stark and Deadpool in the same place
talking like they do that wouldn't be
grating at all you know the one thing
that's really bothering me about all of
this apart from the fact that monopolies
aren't really good for anybody is um
Disney planning to launch their own
streaming service yes in 2019 they want
to compete with Netflix and just like
imagine what's gonna happen when they
strip everything Disney and everything
Fox from Netflix
I mean Netflix has incredible
programming but it's not gonna be able
to keep up and we're gonna see from
Netflix what we've seen with Hulu and
HBO where we are going to need to sign
up to all these different streaming
services because they're all divided but
the other thing is Disney's previous
stake in Hulu has now become a
controlling interest
oh so busy like will now have Hulu as
well oh boy and the studio is gonna have
a 39 percent ownership of Sky TV in
Europe so like Disney that uh that know
that instead of the big shadow of the
death star on the planet it's actually a
desktop with to Mickey Mouse is now you
know it's a great video game Jess um
Skyrim yes and do we have a story about
Skyrim Skyrim is coming to coffee cups
in 2018 no Battlefield Bad Company 2 was
the answer I was looking for
okay fantastic multiplayer fantastic
campaign fantastic characters oh great
fantastic expansion but I don't feel
about company to Vietnam I mean why
can't you say that because there are
rumors going around this week and I will
stress it they our room is but it sounds
like a bad company three might be
happening oh boy because dice is
released scheduled it goes a battlefield
game and a battlefront game year on year
they swap over from each one so
obviously it's been a really long time
since the last bad company game and
what's happened is that the rumor that
is gonna be by company great was shed by
youtuber almighty dag who only has three
videos but um what's really interesting
about this guy is that he correctly
spilled all the details about
battlefield one months before it was
even announced so he got hates the
things correct like the game title being
battlefield one the world war one era
weaponry and even like dev names for
some reason which are for the maps oh
well which leads you to believe he has a
somewhat reliable inside sauce and he's
now created this video claiming that bad
company three is a thing with a crazy
amount of details it's stuff like he's
saying there's gonna be a campaign this
missions that take place like throughout
the conflicts during the mid and post
Vietnam War era up to the Cold War what
he says it's not gonna be historically
accurate but like a bunch of other
things like multi players and bringing
back the focus on tighter maps and
there's gonna be conquest rush
operations and smaller modes honestly
that's to be the iceberg like small
mounds the amount of detail that he's
dropped in this video is crazy and I
mean normally it would it would just be
a broom I like a very very detailed
rumah
but the fact that we've heard it
substantiated informations in this guy
before is interesting although it is
worth noting that prominent battlefield
youtuber that you've probably heard of
level-cap
has made a video listing his battlefield
2018 wish list and in the first part of
the video he talks about how he thinks
that the information provided by
Almighty dag is not true because he has
a few sources inside which says inside
that confirmed it
company's not happening interesting it's
a little strange on the one hand we have
all this information and on the other we
have a pretty strong refuting of that
information yeah it'd be interesting to
see what happens with this one and it's
interesting to hear that bad company 3
is going to be a prequel and not a
conclusion to the fantastic story that
was setting up where I wanna say Russia
was invading the US oh man
great game if you haven't played Bad
Company 2 please go and get it you can
get it on Xbox one
backwards-compatibility it is fantastic
yeah I mean we should confirm all of
this is just one person saying that this
is stuff we don't know any of these
things are actually gonna be a part of
bad company 3 if there even is a bad
company 3 but let us know what you would
want from the game in that comment
section all right well that's everything
we've got time for today do those know
what you thought of these stories in
that comment section and be sure to give
your well-wishing to dance it's been an
absolute delight in a pleasure to work
with one of my best friends and someone
who is so talented in their field and
yeah so say some nice stuff in that
youtube comment section for him just
this once and yes and thanks so much for
putting up with me for the last how
long's it been said that I've been on
here eight months nine months of
co-hosting games one years and I wish
the show all the best without me I hope
you guys you know can't wait to see what
you guys doing new year so take care of
yourselves
have a safe and lovely holiday and make
sure you tell us what games you're
playing during that holiday break please
do we'll be down in that comment section
so if you want to say hi you can say hi
but right now there you're gonna say bye
bye alright now I'm taking this off how
do I do that
yeah is there like a release let me take
these glasses No all right here we go
okay it's okay
I want to be inside that seems like a
like a design flaw
huh I know what you guys worried about
just abundance